because of the political monoculture of
the not just the citizens but those who
are in government that it seems like
they're turning a blind eye to fire loss
violence hello and welcome to
trigonometry I'm Frances Foster I'm
Constantine kisum and this is the show
for you
if you're bored with people arguing on
the internet over subjects they know
nothing about a trigonometry we don't
pretend to be the experts we ask the
experts are fantastic yes this week you
might recognize if you came to see my
Edinburgh show he's an American
journalist and you know welcome to
trigonometry for anyone who doesn't know
you which is an increasingly small
number of people these days just tell us
who are you how are you where you are
what's been your journey through life
most recently became infamous on or
depending on the audence famous for the
for being the victim of an auntie for
beating a robbery in Portland Oregon I I
cover demonstrations there quite
frequently and it was on the 29th of
June that I was attacked and part of
that was caught on video and I was last
with a brain injury from that attack and
we're now as of this recording over two
months since that incident and now
hasn't been a single arrest and one of
the the arguments that was that was used
by some people inexplicably to me to
defend these people beating you up was
the euro right-wing and that somehow
entitles people to beat you up as a
journalist so and you have said that you
are right of sensor so I I wanted just
to explore what that means not that that
would in any way justify anyone
attacking you of course so where are you
politically I'm just curious yeah it was
Joe Rogan who who asked me if there was
I think he asked if there was a gun put
out your head and you had her answer how
would you that was the first time I said
writer centre
I think I've avoided labels for a long
time but I guess if I had to pick I
picked what I said because the positions
that I have that are important to me I
think have been more so aligned with the
right at least in the American context
for example very unpatriotic I'm very
thankful that the United States provided
refuge to my parents who were political
refugees and in the US now the second
scene that is seen as a conservative or
right-wing position to have gratitude
for citizenship and thanking America for
what it is for the freedoms that it
protects right so there's that it's
there's also my parents experience with
escaping communism makes me not have the
luxury of viewing an taifa and other
revolutionary far-left movements with
the same rose-colored glasses so I am
very critical of anti far as anybody who
follows my work knows and I've written
critically about Marxism as well so just
because of I would say it's those two
main things are it's been easy for
people to leave label
me as a conservative writer it took
being charitable there being more the
more trying to delete it delete deed
legitimize me or smear me they'll say
that I'm a far-right person
so you mentioned about auntie for now
aunty for something that I've only
recently become aware of who are antifa
and what what do they want to achieve
it's a movement that began in Europe
particularly in Germany in the years
post-world War two
the subculture that it goes out of is
anti races punk scene and the American
version of it is as we know today very
very recent for not phenomenon so I have
much more knowledge on the US version of
that compared to the the older German or
Western European versions in the US it
it's had some type of presence in some
progressive cities like Portland since
the 2000s but it became a much more
mainstream things from 2016 going
forward I mean you know just rewinding a
few years nobody expected Donald Trump
to win in Portland is a extremely
progressive City it's I explained to
outsiders that it's basically what the
SG SJW ethics and ethos of a university
mainstreamed into entire city into city
government so we had three days of
protests devolved into rioting in
November 2016 and that was the first
time that I saw black bloc anti-fur they
were going around in their mass and
black outfits and destroying property
and starting fires in the street and
because Trump continues to be such a
polarizing figure and a lightning rod
for fear-mongering on the left him and
his administration has been a very
powerful propaganda win for anti fun so
now they are able to point to him or
various things and his his policies or
things that are done in Hinson
as evidence of a sudden and rising
fascism and it's pulled in a large
number of people I mean it's still a
fringe movement but it's grown now to a
point where the city and the public can
no longer ignore so that's why footage
in Portland keeps going viral of these
brawls on the street that look almost
comical from it you know if you're
watching the videos they look outrageous
but like people innocent people regular
citizens get caught up in it and it's on
my perception that because of the the
political monoculture of the not just
the citizens but those who are in
government that it seems like they're
turning a blind eye to far less violence
and Portland's political structure is
unique in that our mayor is also a
police commissioner so you can see the
conflict of interests and he's up for
reelection
so there's just all these variables
coming together of is what you see what
caused kind of what happened to me and I
wasn't the only victim there's been
others before me there'll be those after
me and just through the course of my
speaking up about the vilest militancy
that's happening not just in my city but
in the that particular region of America
the Pacific Northwest I've been targeted
quite a bit in the last wing media and
before we touch on what happened to your
assault what is it that they want to
achieve as a socialist do they want to
overthrow the government introduced and
put in a socialist government are they
communists but what what are they
auntie's fire is a movement I don't ever
describe them as an organization and
some people because they're not too
informed and it described them as a a
group they're not it's it's an ideology
that is made up of many groups and some
of them are ad hoc so you know it could
be something as a group Anti Fog group
that forms in opposition to any event
that's happening
a certain weekend or a conference or
something that they opposed Portland is
a bit different that we do kind of have
a in ante for organization called row
city Antipholus been around since 2007
and they have a Twitter Facebook and
online store so so they they operate
much more as a formal organization and
they were the ones who claimed
responsibility for my attack what they
it's a movement made up of well anti
sergeant Ron so this organization that
exists that has a physical address that
has a store right it's an online online
store okay but but presumably people
know we know who they are
right no we don't we don't they're
entirely anonymous okay we track it
through a bank account I imagine if the
police were interested enough they could
find out at least some other people who
are connected so they claimed
responsibility for beating you up
and yet I presume they haven't been
arrested they haven't been tracked down
they haven't been prosecuted there right
correct and why is that well yeah I
actually don't know I speculate that
it's because it is lack of political
will in Portland to prosecute an tyfa
because they have quite a lot of support
in the city I have my own legal team
that's funded through a legal fund I was
taken on as a client for Publius Lex
which is a civil rights nonprofit and
it's of my view that my civil rights
were violated in that me just working as
a journalist documenting things
happening in a public space have been
continually continually attacked and
intimidated and more recently left with
the serious injury and that the policing
tactics don't change and they just
continually allow citizens to get
assaulted and it's through that legal
fund and my legal team that were doing
our own investigations to see what we
can find because it don't seem like
there are systemic issues important and
that it's not just isolated incidents of
of street violence but I mean this has
been going on for years now
very very few people ever get held
accountable that to me just seems so
bizarre and ridiculous because you were
seriously assaulted I mean I don't know
the American term the British I would
say probably GBH grievous bodily harm of
which someone would go into prison for
six months to a year and the fact that
there doesn't seem to be any willingness
to him to investigate I've never opened
an investigation about what happened
there's an ongoing investigation but the
Portland police aren't keeping me
updated on where they are and the one
thing that I found quite upsetting and
I'm on the left is the lack of sympathy
that I saw from people on the left to
what happened to you is if oh you know
he's on the right therefore he sort of
deserves it which I found to be
abhorrent and an absolute callousness
yeah I think like you know one of your
questions earlier was like what what do
auntie for what the it's a coalition
made up of radical extreme Communists
and anarchists and they really believe
that they're at the vanguard of some
revolution that this is going to be a
cosmic battle with the fascists and that
they are going to be the ones who will
be leading the the anti-fascist side
it's beyond that which sounds outrageous
there is a more coherent political
theory behind it you know my I focus on
anti-fur but I don't think they're like
an exit existential threat to American
democracy or anything and in the United
States as well as this country have
developed democracies there's no way
that a small fringe movement can take
over the country however that doesn't
mean that ant if I can't find success
through other ways and I think what
we're seeing in the u.s. is that one of
the goals is really to normalize
political violence and that used to not
be a partisan issue in the US but now it
has becoming
there are many mainstream politicians
and thinkers and commentators on the
left who who have the view that if
somebody has or is accused of having
abhorrent views they must be shut down
by any means necessary
and that's actually one of the anti-fog
groups adopt that name by any means
necessary so it can be through shutting
them down to redock seing them
intimidating them through assaulting
them and then if need be something like
what happened to me so there's been a
lot of disinformation in misinformation
about me that have come from mt4
supporters and they really accused
believe that I am a far-right threat to
them we'll get to that in a moment Andy
but actually none of that matters if
you're a journalist even if you were a
right-wing journalist who was there with
to misrepresent part of you still
doesn't entitle people to beat you up
that that's not how to save a life
Society works and and the biggest
problem of course with all of this is
that if violence is legitimized I want
legitimized by one side what you're then
doing is you're sending a message the
violence is acceptable what do you think
the fact the genuine far-right which
does exist as a small fringe what are
they going to do and as we know they are
probably better at violence than than
the far left so I don't think it in any
way it matters what your political
opinions are actually for for whether
this was legitimate no it's just not
legitimate and you know you talked about
it being comical initially or being seen
as comical by outsiders
I remember watching prior to your
incident footage of these antiva
protesters and Portland blocking of
streets and directing traffic and then
an old guy in his car being kind of he
tried to drive through and he was
assaulted and and all this stuff and the
police standing there the back just
watching this whole thing and anyone
with any sense could see that that would
then lead to an T for becoming
emboldened so how much of it is as you
say the pill the lack of political will
in the city that has encouraged these
people to feel like they can run around
beating people up yes I I mean
would be just speculation at this point
but my observation is what happens at
these things is these demonstrations as
police will be on the periphery always
within eyesight of sometimes the
violence and things that happen before
the violence so like on May Day what
happened to me was that I had been
punched in the stomach and I reported it
immediately to police who were just
several yards away and there's the
response then and I could still point
out the suspect who was masked but still
within eyesight the response then as
it's been every time inside we will not
approach speak to confront or detain as
a suspect because I could incite the
crowd so anti-fun other far-left
militants have been basically been given
a blueprint it's like if you if we as a
mob promised violence then the police
just wanted to meet and that that video
that you talked about that when they
shot down the traffic on the street that
happens was actually quite routinely
importantly like it's almost to the
point now where like the violence on the
streets is the banality and people don't
even like just two weeks ago in Portland
there was the city was bracing for some
major demonstrations and the fact that
nobody was killed but several people
were injured that was seen as a success
in the city and it was described as
peaceful which was shocking to me some
of the video you seen of people taking
out concrete and throwing it a bus that
was trying to leave I mean you know my
detractors keep bringing up that but
these are the far-right they're extreme
they're white supremacist whatever you
know what happened that day is
regardless of whatever views these
people have within the bus they were
trying to leave the the demonstration
and they were leaving in the area and
they were prevented from leaving because
traffic was shut down because of people
in the street and then these people
rushed the bus and then there was this
footage with the hammer and them trying
in spraying people spring bear mace
inside the bus as they were driving off
like to me it's almost like the views
here
irrelevant it's like this action of this
violence where people are not just
condoning it but cheering them on
because it's these people they don't
like yeah these people they don't like
on the bus but how much of how much
truth is in this idea that is
essentially two groups of extremists
coming together to fight each other
because the the they they are whenever I
see antifa being written about in the
media is always they account to
protesters so the setup is that they are
protesting against other people who've
come to Portland to to spread the
hateful far-right ideas how much truth
is that to that there is some truth to
that but more often than not what
happens is a some type of right-wing or
conservative group will announce that
they are holding some type of event in
Portland it can be something as simple
as a small rally or holding American
flags the left-wing activists and
anti-fur will view that as a provocation
in organized to come in to they say
defend our communities but in in the
language of nt4 what that really means
is come to physically confront them so
there's that sometimes what happens is
that some of the right-wing groups will
go to an event that an tyfa is organized
to in the they would say they're going
there just to watch or listen to observe
peacefully anti-fur view that as a
provocation so I mean it's not like both
sides are equally to blame a both sides
are equally blameless but what I see is
it's more so one side being unable to
accept that there's this small group of
people who have opposing these who want
to speak openly like they can't tolerate
that because they do believe that their
ideas are so dangerous that if we allow
if we give them an inch what we will
have is the Holocaust again essentially
so they use a lot of language from the
interwar years they adopt the symbols of
the aunt the anti-fascist from that time
because they really think that they are
part of that leg
see of the from the interwar years in
Europe it's it's delusional it's
outrageous and it would be funny if
innocent people didn't get caught up in
their violence and Andy how much
responsibility do you think Trump needs
to take for the fact that antifa have
grown because of the use of is rhetoric
when in his political rallies refer I
mean referring to people as sons of
[ __ ] Mexican immigrants using the
word rapists and does that not how he
does he you know I have to take some
responsibility for the fact that this
hard left have become emboldened well
ante tha's issues is with Trump but
primarily they take it out on his
supporters so you know I mean in in the
US and actually all around the world
we've been discussing for years now
problems with Trump's rhetoric and I
just I don't you know if you're like a
it's the same conversation over and over
like he said something offensive he said
something that he didn't walk back very
well and that were just going to be
angry and upset about it well then go
out to the streets and demonstrate I
think what I appreciate about him
speaking out more now about anti foes
like it's bringing attention more to
this extremist movement you know I of
course at the same time I we all have to
recognize that it's not just his things
that he said but I think his lack of
action in being a good unifier has
driven more this polarization in in
America which in turn does empower
anti-fur as well as fringe elements on
the right and so but I think at the end
of the day it's about holding people
accountable for their own actions rather
than
I just think it's too tenuous and vog
and of an argument to say that Trump is
a route a radicalizing figure but would
you not so for instance if you were so
if you're a Latino person and you live
in America you hear him use those words
and you were a young especially a young
man of a certain age a certain certainly
being impressible would that not
radicalize you I can feel that I would
be very angry at it maybe want to
protest against it or get upset and feel
that the American president does not
want to represent me see the only
problem with the argument isn't Aoife
incredibly white right yes they posted
the mug shots of all the people arrested
they're all white oh yeah so so I
understand your argument but it doesn't
seem to be borne out I'm guessing most
of these people the middle class vegans
or whatever you know what I mean yes
there's a demographic Savanti for at
least in Portland well actually in other
cities like DC or Berkeley would have a
predominantly white they will try to
elevate like the few individuals who
they I think they use them as tokens you
know they're trans person of color or
the disabled person to put them at the
front of the line whereas we're black
bloc will stand behind them I mean it's
just robbed a very corporation but I
mean in in response to your question I
think there's nothing wrong with demands
protesting that's part of the American
spirit but like what anti fund the
Allies are doing is it's not lawful
protesting it's shutting down the
streets they call it Dirac action
physical confrontations with people and
the label and the type of people that
they you know jet they sometimes do
genuinely go against oppose true
far-right figures but because those
number people are really small and they
need a constant threat to not only give
themselves meaning but to recruit other
people they've expanded very very
broadly who they consider
or dashes supporting or not see in that
you know now encompasses people like me
for example so it's like and the things
that they do are a criminal and so I
there's a lot too there are many issues
with Donald Trump I don't think that it
that I'm not sure now at this point if
he was just taken out of the picture of
Anti Fog would just go away would be
definitely harder to them to recruit but
many aspects of their ideology or
basically have been mainstreamed by some
of our politicians like a OCE for
example the demonization of law
enforcement the even just dealer just
amazing the concept of sovereignty in
the u.s. so there's been in the past two
months four incidents of immigration
customs enforcement facilities being
targeted and one of them was by an
antiphonal teen in the state of
Washington close to to Portland where
one of the fire bombs of facility tried
to ignite a 500-gallon propane tank and
came down with the rifle he got killed
before he killed anybody but he left
behind a manifesto I'd actually crossed
paths with him before so like I thought
was massively underreported it was it
was so like the street hooliganism on
the street is one aspect of it but it's
the ideology itself is very extreme I
mean it's it's like revolution by any
means necessary and we will take up arms
and you know the the shoot at the mass
shooter in Ohio recently he didn't leave
behind a manifesto as far as we know but
Lisa's social media footprint can give
us a clue in his views and he was
extremely he was a part of anti fightin
that he attended the demonstrations in
his state expressed support for their
views and so I'm not sure if we can even
really say that anti fighting a lot that
there's no body count on the anti foot
side anymore
and we'll see what the investigation
finds but you know this we don't know
anything about the Ohio shooters
ideology beyond his social media and he
did leave a very extensive history of
support for violent violent militancy
and why do you think because when I said
I was in holiday and I saw both of those
shootings which happen in quick
succession and the first one I thought
it wasn't it was it in Texas yes so the
first one was in Texas and I was having
to a Latin American commuting oh it was
awful awful of course it was and then
there was another one that happened and
that didn't seem to get as much press or
that might have been just what happened
in Europe and the way the BBC presented
it because the BBC pushed forward the
one that happened in Texas and that one
it seemed to be swept under the carpet
is that fair to say
it for sure received less attention I
mean there were fewer fatalities and
Ohio shooting but still nine people were
killed us a lot and so I think you know
it's about media narratives it's the
fact that the your pastor shooter in
taxes was targeting Mexicans and he left
behind a manifesto where his ideas
created easy headlines for example
because he had done a phobic views like
it's much easier to sensationalize that
type of straw and make people go crazy
on social media was the Ohio shooter was
a bit more complicated in that he didn't
believe in a right-wing manifesto in his
social media account certainly didn't
show him being sympathetic to white
supremacy intent that and quite the
contrary so I think ideology has a lot
to do with that I mean you see it often
when criminal violent acts are committed
by somebody who is part of a
historically marginalized community
there's I think what journalists don't
want to focus too much on it always
afraid of how it could negatively impact
the perception of the community whereas
if that suspect but criminal is a
white man particularly if he is seen as
potentially conservative anyways and
it's a free-for-all so that's just the
nature of the media in the United States
as well as this country and how much do
you think this is about language because
we've had a number of people on this
show talking about you know in Britain
brexit voters being called Nazis being
milkshake brexit Pro brexit politicians
being called not is being milkshake how
much of this do you think is about the
fact that if you keep calling everyone
Nazis there will be some people who
eventually actually believe it and then
I mean look if I thought that they were
genuine Nazis coming right well I I
probably would use violence to try and
defend myself you know what I mean so
how much of it is about we've we've
managed to persuade ourselves that
there's this horde of Nazis coming for
all of us and some of these people are
now buying into that idea when the
reality wouldn't suggest that you know I
think it would be easier to for me to
step back and just sort of accept that
[Music]
the nature of of ad hominem insults is
like you know constantly trying to outdo
the other and so like if Nazis had just
remained an insult
and stayed that was used as part of this
rhetoric then that's one thing but what
happened is puncher Nazi became a meme
that was quite celebrated you know like
Richard Spencer is an easy person for
for people to hate but then as I said a
moment ago the definition of Nazi has
become kind of meaningless now and so
it's just applied very very broadly and
there's people now who think well this
person's a Nazi it's okay to punch him
or her right or do something worse so
language has something to do with it but
I think it's more so that the actions
now the response to people you dislike
like shutting them down through violent
talks is seen as acceptable I mean
in this country that milk shaking became
this new phenomenon that very quickly
crossed the Atlantic and it was pretty
much universally celebrated by your
chartering classes as well as the
American ones too I mean it was
basically described the American
left-wing poetry as a cute form of
political dissent we can saw how quickly
that that slippery slope right and like
what happened to me that day the milk
shaking served a particular purpose
primarily one to mark me as a target for
everybody else in the crowd because
there are many people who knew my name
and my writings but didn't know my face
so you know that literally yeah it's
like a big arrow direct to me once I
have all that stuff on me and then
secondly it blinds you as well when it
goes in your face and your eyes and you
can't even see so it's very insidious
and I am concerned that there's like it
should really you know in developed
liberal democracies like political
violence should be something that's
universally condemned but now it's not
it's kind of like you hear a lot of I
don't support violence but these people
are XY and Z right yeah oh it's this is
despicable and we talked about at the
time with many people I mean the idea
that you can go around throwing stuff at
people because you don't agree with them
is not what a democracy is and it just
it should be condemned by everybody
irrespective of whether you agree with
the people or not and the fact that a
lot of people felt very comfortable with
that
it was deeply troubling to me just a
milkshake and alone what happened to use
obviously incredibly serious and and
much more clearly defined but I've
always said that you know milk attacking
someone by throwing the milkshake at
them they don't know what's in that cup
they don't know and so the whole point
of it is you're scaring the person I
mean and they don't know what that
liquid is I could be acid it could be
anything
and of course it's intimidation is
designed specifically to prevent people
from speaking it's political violence
designed to shut down discussion that's
that's what it is guys we wanted to
tell you we're very excited to say we've
got a new sponsor which is hellofresh
indeed we have hellofresh
is a UK's leading recipe box service
delivering fresh pre-portioned
ingredients and step-by-step recipes to
your door it is the easy convenient way
to cook delicious dinners from scratch
every single time choose your favorites
from 19 recipes every week they have a
whole range of options there for you
including recipes that are ready in
under 20 minutes there's family
favorites there's British cuisine
there's world cuisine hellofresh we're
offering trigonometry fans 60 pounds or
4 boxes to take advantage of that go to
hello fresh Kota UK enter our special
code which is of course trigonometry and
enjoyed delicious dinners without any of
the drama the fresh ingredients come
direct from suppliers ie
they've been picked by Constantine's
family you can tell Francis studied
geography at a British school because he
can't tell the difference between Russia
and Romania doesn't matter mate same
thing breaks it means breaks it and the
great thing is it's been pre-portioned
for you so there's no food waste
just like in my home country of
Venezuela the great thing we've had
fresh is that you're gonna be able to
choose from 19 different recipes every
week so there is something for everybody
you're going to be able to eat with you
kids it's going to be no fuss dinnertime
it's going to be solved yeah I really
like the rapid box which allows you to
cook things in under under 20 minutes
but the great thing about hellofresh as
well is it actually allows you to open
up your cooking range so most households
on average have about six recipes that
they cook regularly hellofresh has up to
19 so you can kind of expand a little
bit in terms of your cooking and of
course they also don't have a fixed
subscription so there's no term you can
cancel you can skip weeks you can change
the size of the box you can change the
livery address you can do all kinds of
stuff to suit your life to enjoy
delicious moment head over to hello
fresh coat UK choose your box choose
your delivery slot and add your favorite
recipes discover the easy way to get
delicious dinners from scratch and if
you do that you'll get sick ABS just
like me hello fresh we're offering
trigonometry fans 60 pounds off four
boxes to
take advantage of that go to hello fresh
taco de UK enter our special code which
is of course trigonometry and enjoy
delicious dinners without any of the
drums let's talk about some of the stuff
that's happened more recently because
one of the things that we we know now is
that there was some criticism of you and
an attempt to present you in a
particular light and I wanted to speak
to you about that and see what you had
to say about it because there was this
video released it's an 18 minute video I
find it quite boring and difficult to
watch but basically if if I can
represent what is being said about it
and then you can say what you think
about it and correct me if any of my
thing is not accurate to what people are
saying right what I think people are
saying is you were part you were walking
together with a right-wing group of is a
patriot prayer right who who were
planning to attack a bar in which these
anti-fur people hang out and you were
participating or at least observing a
conversation in which they were planning
this violent attack and people have used
that to essentially say and Andino is
not an objective journalist what he is
is someone who hates anti-fur so he
records all their violent crimes but
when it comes to right-wing violence
which also does exist he doesn't record
that he doesn't present that and
therefore he presents a skewed picture
and they've then gone on to say that
that's why you left Colette so tell us
about that yes so I left quite like a
week before the slightest controversy
broke out it was a mutual decision I'm
moving on to other projects I'm going to
be working on a book just don't have
time to continue to be working with
Colette and it's been a great experience
so I'm very thankful for the time that
I've had there those who dislike me use
we're trying to link it with the latest
outrage this video that's come out
that some headline subscribers damning
and has field very serious accusations
against me actually I think criminal
accusations of criminality and that I
was party to a violent criminal
conspiracy conspiracy or had knowledge
of it that withheld it from the
authorities it's absolutely all untrue
is rubbish this video I actually
encourage everybody to watch it it's
kind of like washing paint dries eighty
minutes so that was recorded on the
first of May 2019 made a there were a
series of demonstrations throughout the
day I had been documenting it it was
early in the day that I had been punched
in the ABS in in and sprayed with silly
string and so that happened all before
this video started there was a
right-wing demonstration where they were
holding flags over bridge and after that
was over they were milling around the
street and walking around I was just
following them it was really uneventful
it's actually quite boring and I was
thinking I was looking at my phone which
you can actually see in the video one to
see how the other journalists had
covered the protests from earlier in the
day so does anything else that I missed
because it was happening at different
parts of the city and I was trying to
see if anybody had caught video and me
getting assaulted so that's what I was
looking at and concentrated on I only
heard snips snippets of what these
people were talking about and none of it
to me was interesting it was like where
are we going to go is anybody else
joining us what's going on like so I
didn't record that it wasn't and I mind
you I need to point out I wasn't only
photo journalist I was there there are
three other people including a local
left-wing journalist by the way so none
of us found I knew this interesting
there was at one point where people have
said some of the headlines have been
completely false demonstrably false if
you watch the video it's saying that I
lost while people were planning a an
attack I never left in the video there
was a one point where I did give
faint smile I recall them saying
something about how they were really
outnumbered and I was just at that time
thinking about like this is what you
know they're always outnumbered 10 to
one if they're lucky like this is a
futility of their demonstrations in
progressive Portland and that was spun
as me being improving or supportive of
whatever happened next and I don't think
it was apparent to any of us there what
was going to happen next because even
this this video who was reported by an
undercover anti-fur activists someone
who had been undercover for two years
and this is like the climax of his work
right one it was selectively released in
that he doesn't show any any of what
happened actually up the ante for pub
that was hosting the anti foot party
doesn't show any of that and that that
was whereas I was seriously assaulted
there as well and so he loved lead
accusations against me anonymously
it's an unverified well one is an
anonymous person so it's unverified
source and that it the fact is this he
was interviewed and it went on a on the
left wing blog and called the Portland
mercury which is also a paper and you
know it's like this whole like watching
myself being smeared in real-time and
made into somebody or not has been
really fascinating kind of surreal it's
like seeing how it's a game of telephone
almost like this and all the players are
you know the the writers a HuffPo box or
vice and then all the Twitter check
marks people who kind of parted the same
left-wing Scorchers partisan ideological
write writers and it's just like Oh some
decide and he was laughing when when he
get Andy's laughing in a damning video
let's repeat on the headlines and over
and over over and it just you know they
really depend on people not watching it
[Music]
what happened next on in that video is
well I went to the bar and and actually
in an interview with this anti anonymous
interior activist he stopped recording
at one point
not to call the police but to call the
people out the anti-fur party you know
so if this was if he was really
witnessing a violent criminal conspiracy
I wonder why he didn't call police and
this video footage even at the very end
of the interview he said he didn't
realize what he had caught until much
until sometime later before releasing it
so it wasn't apparent to him and he was
right there talking to the people and I
was walking around the area sometimes
close mostly far away as well as being
concentrated with things on my phone
okay so just to be clear what you're
saying is at no point did you feel that
these people were about to go and attack
someone in a bar I didn't have a full
picture that would have led me to that
conclusion
correct and Andy do you think we're
entering this really dangerous period
not for journalism where every
journalist and every journalistic
publication seems to be advocacy
journalism and that people just want to
push their narrative and they will twist
the facts in order to suit their own
narrative and actually what happened the
facts nobody seems to care about anymore
yes you know and I need to you know self
introspection is very important to me
and integrity and all that so I need to
point out that not everything that the
critics say about me are wrong some of
it has merit for example just the nature
of on the ground breaking news reporting
with things that I have many things
happening at the same time sometimes in
that very moment you may get a detail
wrong you don't have the advantage of
the multiple angles that come out in the
hours later and of course you know the
basically the crowdsourcing of that
checking that's something rahama thing
would be a good example where the hammer
was on the bus but you may initially
mentioned it being I actually never
described where it came from but in the
video you do see that it at one point
one of the people from the antipholus I
did have the hammer I didn't know that
it Richardson came from inside yeah I
came out and corrected the record for
that and then I released a video that I
two days a few days later that I didn't
have access to initially that was like
the full-on cuts that showed you know
the group of people descending on that
bus kind of like the whole like there's
contacts to that hammer being taken out
you know like you can make an argument
of potentially with self-defense and if
you watch the unedited video it was
people from the outside who charged
towards the door by the way so yes
there's I had to correct that there was
some other small details so this is
stuff that it's like I mean relatively
small more mistakes that I correct but
then they used to sort of say that
everything I say is a lie and I you know
it's like I'm just one individual
working as a as an independent
journalist a freelance writer you know
you see huge mistakes being done by
people like on MSNBC or seen and and
they have an entire department of fact
checkers and editors behind them and
they still get some mistakes they start
you know it's just so like taking cheap
shots at me like that I think is
disingenuous particularly when these
writers are either in DC or New York
City and not on the ground employment
and seeing and witnessing what happens I
mean you know it's just it doesn't seem
a good faith argument but you know I
there is some merit to it and that I
have gotten things wrong that I correct
but the other smears that are coming out
now that I am that I coordinate with
far-right people it's it's outrageous so
there was another news story that came
out in the Willamette week which is a
local paper in Portland I am and they
had has attained a a secret recording of
I guess men that were inside that bus I
think I don't know if it was before or
after that hammer thing I think was
after so they released that and at one
point one of the men was talking about
how and ego got beat up because he
turned down the proud boys offer of
security mmm
and then the the commentary in a new
story not an opinion piece by the way
new story was that this was evidence of
me colluding with the power boys and I
don't know if I'm it's it's like I've
it's like we're reading and listening to
different things because you know there
was an outpouring of support to me after
the May Day attack where I was sprayed
with bear mace in the face and was
blinded and I had so I had a whole bunch
of people that I didn't know offered to
be volunteers security if I go out and
cover more protests I turn down those
offers because I wanted to maintain my
independence and now that is used as
evidence and coordination so I don't you
know like this whole thing seems like
went through the looking-glass I you
know I feel like I don't know if the
world's going matter if it's me that
it's like it's amazing that like for me
the victim are multiple multiple
assaults in in in having my dress Docs
and part of the reason I'm in the UK is
actually was because they continue
violent threats to myself that I've been
reported to police and I just need to
get away far away from the US and like
me being the victim of all that is now
somehow spun around is I am like an
extreme violent person who is the
aggressor who deserves all this or was
brought it on myself it's it's almost
like a dream it just it doesn't seem
like this is really reality to me it's
scary to me how many people are
delighted about what's happened I mean
I've before interview I watched a clip
of The Young Turks and David Pakman both
talking about this and particularly the
Young Turks I mean the way that they try
and present themselves as a objective
journalist and then he goes yeah well
conservatives don't feel any empathy and
and it's just like how can you even
pretend to be in any way objective when
you when you're talking that way and
neither of us is conservative we just
try and talk to people who who may we
may disagree with or humor but you can't
you can't talk about people in that way
and then present
objective but the the they used exactly
the phraseology that you talked about
something along the lines of well of
course violence shouldn't be used but
and and that happened in that video a
couple of times and I was like do you
understand what you're saying anything
you said before the word but doesn't
count you know so obviously there is
there is a large group of people who are
very happy about you being treated in
this way yes why why do they see you're
such a threat do you think because I'm a
decent professional person who has quite
reach in my writings like many people
who have been very critical event if
I've been confined to other blogs or
YouTube videos whereas my writings have
been published in The Wall Street
Journal and the National Review the New
York Post and I was was Colet and so
it's just like and what with what
happened to me in the 29th of June it it
kind of woke up some of the politicians
to start speaking about antipholus
extremism which hadn't been done before
so I I am a perceived as a threat
understandably to them because for so
long they've just been receiving pretty
much only favorable coverage and the
fact that now there's somebody who's
can't be relied on to provide favorable
coverage consistently who calls him out
in their actions and who has a reach
that you know I have quite a large reach
on Twitter my the places that published
me have a large people large amounts of
people reading it it's they see that
their control over the narrative is
slipping a bit and actually they really
depend on that that control over how
they were perceived because their
actions and ideology is so extreme that
they really do have to rely on those who
are willing to whitewash and rationalize
the things they do and once that gets
challenged whoever's doing the
challenging needs to be taken out by any
means necessary Andy I'm you could
assure me as being a very bright person
in the truest sense of the word
you you
could be a hell of a lot easier if you
didn't do this why do you feel the need
as a journalist to put yourself in the
foreign line and to put your body on the
line as well I have a lot of journalist
friends who told me and you just move on
to write other things like the pile on
that happens every time you do one of
these things the the scrutiny on every
single detail every single word you say
like it's just not worth of that living
that type under that type of pressure
and on top of you know the threats of
violence and I think I've refused to be
cowed because the things that ante has
been doing to me for months is to
terrorize me into silence and I think
with the the crowd beating on the 29th
of June that was meant to like attempt
to permanently silent it silenced me and
they failed and I just I refused to give
them that type of victory you know of
course moving forward I'm much more wise
about how I cover events in that eye
I no longer unfortunately no longer
believe that the Portland Police are
willing to uphold the law for example so
even if I'm covering an T foot in right
in front of police like I was naive to
think that the police would actually
protect in you know a citizen just in a
public space so there's things that I've
change but I'm sticking on this there's
other things I write about that makes
people on the far left and a lot 8 me
you know I write about hate crime hoaxes
quite that was originally how I kind of
started receiving some notoriety earlier
this year and that challenges in weakens
anti-fur narrative which is that we are
living in such an oppressive dangerous
time that violence is justified against
the oppressors and the presses can be
anything from regular trump supporters
to those truly on the far right but
that's I mean that's a huge spectrum of
people that they all oppose with the
same hatred and violence so I'm going to
continue to speak out I recognize and
and you know I want to be a better
Journal
to the mistakes that I made that I've
had to correct I mean it's embarrassing
every time that happens but you know any
journalist what's integrity recognizes
that and works to improve on it so you
know I have goals that I had to work on
for myself moving forward at the same
time you know when something's are not
right lie against me as some of these
headlines are right now they're outright
lies and you know I just like to say
I've my legal team is aware of it
because I think some of the claims
against me rises to the level of by the
libel and defamation well I was gonna
ask you you're hidden in London in
England we had something not similar but
we had some protests recently do you
think we're gonna see more of this
across the world
he's running battles between people on
the two extremes the issues that we're
seeing with anti far more recently is
really kind of confined to the
Anglosphere I mean anti-fur activism in
Germany is the kind of entirely
different thing because they actually do
have a history that goes back decades of
this group and some of the ideas that
are from America I notice are balancing
off to the far left militants in Britain
what happened I was encouraged to see
was that the London Metropolitan Police
even without having any of the heavily
militarized gear that you see American
police they were able to contain law and
order for example last weekend when
there was an ante for demonstration
against Tommy Robinson supporters they
were marching on the street so they had
disrupted traffic and before they could
really do that for much longer the
police just surrounded them in such
large numbers that they couldn't do
anything in the and the police pushed
them to the pavement so they won they
could no longer disrupt traffic some of
them were carrying some small sticks
that had sharpened ends that was taken
and it seemed like because the police
are quick to act they're not emboldened
to see how much he can push because in
Portland it wasn't
like right away that you know they were
attacking people on the street it was
like okay first we're gonna take over
the streets and we can do it
secondly some of us are gonna bring in
bats or brass knuckles or small knives
in bear mace and we get away with it and
the next thing is we're gonna start
using it like so you know like the
incidence of political violence in
Britain that I've seen have been much
more isolated and small I mean I know
that some of the controversial political
people who ran as any peas not too long
ago were targeted but like that's the
violence that I saw there wasn't
anything like what we see continue to
see important so I think that as more
attention is brought to the dangers of
normalizing political violence in
liberal democracies I think police will
naturally face more pressure to do more
unfortunately important than our police
commissioner's also our mayor so that
may be the one exception but what I'm
really concerned about it's just that
the wider public will accept and
encourage those types of violent actions
because they believe that it's for a
better cause or good cause I think
that's extremely damaging to how
citizens relate to one another it's like
if you erase the line between thoughts
ideas and actions like but I mean there
are many parts of the world actually
were depending on the just the idea that
you hold you can be put to dust for it
either by the state or through a mob
lynching and so it worries me that many
influential people here who have
benefited from the the rights that come
in the civil rights that come in liberal
democracy that they are in a way of
working to weaken those sort of like
those rules that are codified into law
but as well as expected
between one another that's what I'm
concerned about and do you think we're
going to be able to because at the
moment I mean maybe it's just you know
the effect to the internet you look at
the internet everybody seems to be more
polarizing over you know we seem to be
brighten ourselves into certain camps do
you think that we're going to be able to
heal this division or do you see it just
becoming worse and worse well in your
country you're dealing was brexit now
and it does seem like it's getting worse
and worse but you have I mean your Prime
Minister was hated as he is by some
people is I also see him doing good
effort to be a unifier in America is a
bit harder and you know the president
you know that's Trump is Trump that he
hasn't changed a bit from the campaign
days in 2015 and so there going to be
people who will try everything they can
to exploit this polarization because it
benefits them politically and so I'm a
bit more hopeful about Britain than I am
about America in this regard well I
don't want me to do this before we asked
our last question is that do you think
Trump's can it reacted
yes so do I it's interesting all right
well there's Dole last question no I'm
not happy now so the question that we
always ask Andy is what is the one thing
people aren't talking about but actually
really should be talking about well this
is sort of the paradoxes a lot of people
talking about social justice extremism
and craziness in the Universities and
American universities example but also
with some campuses in UK I mean your
Student Union is particularly outrageous
and I think what's not being looked at
in this particular instance is that this
idea those ideas that were formally
confined to certain disciplines in
university they now have outlets to be
mainstreamed across the rest of society
yeah we read the Guardian yeah well
that's it and this is why we talked
about the contract that I turned and
that's why I turned it down because I'm
going it's gonna bleed into real life
all the social justice stuff it's gonna
bleed into real things it's not just
gonna stay at the University because
these people are gonna grow up and
they're gonna become politicians judges
journalists and they're gonna spread all
this crap and that's why I think people
who are saying need to need to stop it
and say something which is what you're
doing so all the best of luck to you
with it we wish you well take care of
yourself thank you wear a helmet or
something at least if you do go into
these places Joe Rogan said to you you
should bring some big guys with you but
you're clearly not planning to do that
are you no you know I can't reveal my
reporting tactics but there are many
ways when you get creative of how you
can cover a demonstration without
necessarily putting yourself there okay
okay he's going to use drones you know
in Russia this is completely irrelevant
to what we're talking about but in
Russia they use drones to fly over all
the politicians and oligarchs mansions
to show how these people are living so
they infiltrate their whole thing with
the drone and then they do a whole
report about how I told you build using
stolen
ah no you gotta there's an idea for you
anyway thank you so much for coming on
Andy we really appreciate your time
always always follow Andy we'll put the
thing in the bottom of the video on
Twitter he puts his reporting there
follow us at trigger pod on other social
media and we will see you in a week from
now and also as well please leave us a
nice review on iTunes if you're enjoying
the podcast or the show tell another
person if you're worried about it just
tell them quietly and we will see you
next week thank you so much
[Music]